what's going on reject nation we're
going to watch today from a channel
called
the things 15 spider-man improvised
scenes
you thought were real now when it comes
to reaction to these list videos i want
to try something a little different
i think that reactors sometimes do where
they pause to stop to talk about things
now we usually let the whole thing play
in its entirety for like 10 to 20
minutes
and then talk afterwards but i want to
try it out
i know there are some people who just
automatically hate change wanna just uh
see how it is for us it'll be different
for us too yeah we'll learn
and grow together yeah and feel the the
joy
sometimes unscripted moments breathe
more life into a scene
the adults are talking and other times
they
luckily in the mcu the improvisation
gene is impeccably strong amongst its
actors
so in this video we're taking it is a
gene all of spider-man's unscripted
moments that completely took the films
to another level
okay let's talk about this that's the
breakdown
action we all know tony stark isn't one
to get himself caught up in emotional
moments i heard about this spider-man
homecoming peter parker
learned that in a pretty awkward way
after tony stark has a talk with peter
in his car
he reaches over to open the car door but
peter thinks he's actually leaning in
for a hug
remember that's not a hug i'm just
grabbing the door for you
well check out what tom holland had to
say about the scene well that was
actually an improvised moment
i think i just was trying to [ __ ] him i
just thought it would be funny if i
hugged him
the hilarious moment was completely
improvised for laughs but robert downey
jr went along with it
speaking about tony stark whoa already
damn tony and peter c that is an iconic
scene that is
so funny it's crazy how much oh like i
thought it was all gonna be like tom
holland stuff but it's just so funny to
see how much
robert downey jr himself yeah even the i
am iron man line
yeah which i don't think would be on
this list he improvised all his lines
his toes
all every line has ever been improvised
that's great that's such a what made
that moment so funny too
it's not just tony stark's delivery uh
robert downey jr so what made it so
funny
was tom holland's reaction absolutely of
how he really thought he was getting
that's what made it so uncomfortably
feels so real it feels absolutely
natural damn
it was oh girl that is gold that is
gold absolutely in his emotions during
the final moments of avengers infinity
war
he was nothing but emotional same mr
stark as spider-man turned into
nothingness in his arms
we were all a petal of tears when he
desperately chants
i don't want to go i don't want to go
please
that was all tom holland again the
director gave him free reign on the
death scene
and tom even if he doesn't think it was
that spectacular himself
i don't want to go three times in a row
so it's not that amazing of an ad-lib
it's hard to believe spider-man is one
of tom's first big roles
tom holland and zendaya's chemistry is
off the charts
peter parker and mj are like magic on
screen together
and a lot of that is thanks to the
actors off-screen friendship
according to zendaya tom has a habit of
deviating from the script
but thankfully they're so in tune with
one another that she was able to respond
right back
no matter how annoyed she was it just
kept
improving he just did not stick to the
script he was trying to throw me off
what's your favorite peter in mj scene
she knows i told her
he didn't tell me i figured it out if
there's one they don't tell us
they're just all improvised interact
with one another
but the truth is a lot of the time we're
watching their off-screen relationships
shine through the camera
remember in spider-man far from home ned
walks in on mj and peter while he's
changing into his spider
this happened in real life costume looks
great
for the costume party well ned wasn't in
on the fact that mj had found out their
secret and tried to play it off
ned's actor jacob battalion actually
said that was one of his favorite scenes
to shoot
because he got to improv all his
comments there was a lot of laughter on
saturday
we have to give jake that's cool playing
such a convincing role as mysterio
who knew that he would actually turn out
as a villain in the end but it looks
like we should be praising jake for more
than just his impeccable acting skills
according to the actor he and director
john watts came up with a lot of
unscripted
moments for his character that ended up
in the film we don't know what specific
scenes these moments are in
but let's just appreciate mysterio for a
sec
somebody get this stupid costume off
it's so comforting to see the two of
them interact on screen
but you'll be shocked to find out that a
lot of their scenes were unscripted as
well
one specific improvised moment in
spider-man homecoming happened while
they're eating in the thai restaurant
sometimes you have to say larb before
you talk to me their conversation was
just something the actor made up on the
fly with some guidance from the director
yet again we have another improvement so
all the relationships
built on it frost it's in captain
america civil war
check it out i'm gonna sit here so you
move the leg
tony stark telling peter to move over
might seem like it was in character
and it is but it was also robert downey
jr's way of telling tom holland to scoot
over onto his set marker without ruining
the entire take
funnily enough and ended up in the final
cut can you even
see in these
but they are substantial but i've seen
that happen many
many times actually uh on like during
plays
and of course when i'm like a shadowing
a set or something like that when you
have an
actor who's just trying to help another
actor who might be nervous or might be
making a mistake
and they'll improvise to guide them to
get them back on track
and that's just a sign of what makes
robert downey jr the professional actor
that he is because he's still
keeping it like within the moment oh
he's keeping it so lived in because
honestly it's the little nuances it's
the littlest lines like that like
okay marissa's homemade a larvae line
it's a funny line
those are all funny we don't know the
specifics of like what jake gyllenhaal
improvise and i like the encouragement
of actors
being able to go unscripted but those
tiniest bits of
lines make a character feel and a scene
feel that much more lived in
and it says so much more about the
dynamics of those characters
like like tom holland couldn't say
something like that to robert
junior but robert jr like that to him in
a moment like that you know
absolutely i thought what they were
initially getting at was just like oh
yeah it's just something he threw into
the scene and then the fact that it's
also yeah
serving that purpose of you know it's
like actor generosity it's like
within the moment without breaking you
know what could be a great take which
wound up being the used take you know
that he had the presence of mind to do
that like that that made that a real gem
yeah and it also goes to even further
enhance the mentorship dynamic between
the two
yeah and like on and off screen yeah
that's really cool like especially when
you're shadowing uh
jacob battle on and the you know zendaya
and tom hall in chemistry how there's an
off-screen elements that come into the
fold here
that's the beauty of improvised moments
is that a lot of the time the chemistry
you form off screen can
can translate here on screen you read
each other
soon got his moment to shine in
spider-man as his character nick fury he
even got sassy with spider-man
although the line wasn't even scripted
when peter admits he's a little hesitant
to join their newest plan
fury says no way
second they brought this up the line was
improvised but jake gyllenhaal jumped in
to confirm it was 100
unscripted i'm here to attest that was
improvised
that is a classical that again that is
such a sam jackson line
and for as much as people dog and i mean
this doesn't just fix like you know
committee or whatever but as much as
people dog on the mcu for having a
committee i do love
that this at least for the spider-man
world is showing like yeah bring your
personality leave your stamp on it and
maybe we'll put those moments like
in the trailer that is one of the meme
lines from spiderman far from home
[ __ ] please you've been in space a
great line too that's a great line
and it sounds like something where
writers wrote that for sam jackson but
to know he came up with that you're like
oh that is
that that sounds even more believable
so great wonderful that's great despite
his hesitancy with nick fury
peter was all in for helping out iron
man on his avengers infinity war mission
but tony stark wasn't having it or
should we say robert downey jr wasn't
having it
while iron man is having a discussion
with doctor strange peter chimes in that
he's back up i'm back up no
you're still away the adults are talking
but that was yet again another
improvised line between the unscripted
heroes tom holland and robert downey jr
what spider-man far from home what the
robert downey pause button
wait a minute i i didn't even think they
would have like two cameras rolling
i know and in a situation like that with
that kind of set with
yeah such complex lighting and green
screen considerations and all other
manner of things
like yeah because you would have to have
a shot on tom holland and shot on robert
danny jr which is
that's not like ridiculous to do that
but usually with sets
like that for something like infinity
war you're doing that one shot at a time
that's four hours of work to rig both of
these
it's complicated one of them i mean even
if we were to do
something like that just with john and i
in a room that would be complicated
just to just to set up two cameras like
that it sounds
it might just sound like two cameras but
when you have to factor in
everything it's you have to do a lot of
adjustments
and lights it really like to get more
than one camera on an angle it takes a
lot of
lighting consideration especially
especially on a set like that and it's
so
snappy the way that line is that i'm
wondering
how quick they made it in the edit like
did they
like did they do that thing where you
know that tom holland says his line and
they have the end of his line
carry on to tony stark's shot a little
bit later on a little bit earlier on
you know like right before he says the
stowaway line do you want to try yeah
yeah ryan george cut thing back and
forth
yeah there's a little piece of over yeah
sell it that much more
well and the other thing that's got me
wondering and i don't get the
sense that any of these have been like
gone back and retaken but i know
sometimes like an improv line will get
thrown out and then
for the consideration of well that was
so good we
know we probably want the option of
using it we might have to you know go
back
and kind of work it into the scene you
know shot wise too
so it feels like these might could have
easily just been edited in but
you never know damn that's impressive
absolutely what if it was just that
quick back of release robert
is full of european landmarks that make
the entire movie stunning they improvise
london
a lot of them do get destroyed they
improvised
a specific landmark the london tower the
film's final battle takes place in
london
and supposedly during this scene the
cast shot so many versions because of
their ability to improvise
you'd never be able to tell in the final
cut they join forces like the power
rangers
you're thinking voltron you think you're
full try
drax's line so this actually makes me
realize now
too that that makes sense why john watts
probably hires
so many comedians yeah since he allows
for so much improvisation on set um
because those sound like improvised
lines yeah i'm wondering like
is uh is captain america's little uh you
know workout tape gonna pop up in here
somewhere because now i'm thinking who
else in the mcu connected to the
spider-man universe like it seems yeah
like improv what i've learned from this
video
is that improv is part of the life's
blood that's probably
made these spider-man movies as
successful as they are because they are
so lovable and endearing well that's
where the humor and personality comes in
but i did remember thinking there was
some criticism but far from home of
how much of a comedy it was fair yeah
and those lines
the thing is out of all the lines we've
heard so far those sound like improvised
lines
you know that sounds like comedians on
set making making lines
i like it i thought it was funny i'm not
i'm not part of the complaint category
of that but it is like
a person's pop culture jokes it does
sound like
yeah this person got a chance to really
improvise yeah where the other stuff was
more
subtle and it feels not maybe not subtle
but a little bit more lived in it within
the scene itself
do you want better why is gamora it's
one of the things
i've heard about that that came out of
avengers infinity war
even if spider-man's life was literally
being threatened in the scene
the line however was actually ad-libbed
by drax's actor dave bautista
the rest of the actors including tom
holland are just so professional that
they rolled with it the camera operator
even seemed to be quick to react
michael keaton got some time to shine in
spider-man oh of course i didn't think
about it
didn't make the final cut according to
tom holland keaton actually made a
direct reference to his role as batman
in
80s his character vulture is a little
confused as to why spider-man would save
him
and after tom holland delivers his
because i'm spider-man
keaton supposedly responded but i'm
batman
we don't know if the line was part of
the script but tom holland seemed to be
hinting it was ad-libbed like we
oh man that was ad-libbed or included in
the script with full knowledge it would
come right back out
of course that would have been yours it
wouldn't be like you've gotta be powered
dc has worked tirelessly to keep it out
of our hands
you know i had the impression with
michael keaton that
like he wanted to leave batman behind or
something like that
batman behind that sounds like a batman
interesting
pornographic that's his geriatrics
he want that he wanted to leave batman
behind i can't get over that
but then you know think about how he
said it there and he did that
commencement speech where he ended it
with i'm batman
like okay i feel like he's been wanting
to i feel like he he misses that
maybe i feel like he misses batman what
i learned from watching birdman
is that probably he's a little tormented
by some of the experience but would
definitely jump at the chance to go back
in a big you know better way
so yeah i'm not surprised at all he
would have thrown that in there i wish
we could see it
before jake gyllenhaal played the
perfect mysterio
and a lot of why his character is so
epic may be because of how well he got
along with tom holland
according to tom mysterio and spider-man
were actually meant to bump heads a lot
however while filming their interactions
turned out to be more friendly
the directors decided to let them head
off the script and build their own
relationship between the characters they
basically became bffs good luck kid
i'll give you about a 50 50 chance
you're pretty awkward so we also see
spidey's actual bff ned get his own
romantic names
really quick i actually think that's a
really interesting choice
because they're strangers to each other
in the movie
and i've heard like people doing like
actors doing that for
movies where you know like oh they're
supposed to have a long history of a
friendship or something like that
and then if you watch the intern to me i
just chalked it up to the fact that this
jake gyllenhaal
yes because jade children's that much
charisma well no
if you've seen jake gyllenhaal
interviews with his co-stars
he just looks like him and ryan gosling
have this amazing thing where they just
look like
everyone loves to get along with them
yeah they love to
like the interviews they do with them
they just seem like they love
bonding and hanging out with them which
is why they play such
tormented people
but when i when when i think about like
the script with far from problems like
yeah eventually he comes like closer to
him and starts viewing peter parker
starts getting manipulated and viewing
him like a mentor
i get that at the same time though they
start off as strangers to each other
and normally when they have actors do
that that's when
their characters are already supposed to
have a history with each other like i
wouldn't be surprised if i heard that
with jacob and tom holland yeah
you know like oh we had them hang out
with each other before they started
filming
so that way they could really build in
that chemistry yeah so i actually think
that's kind of interesting they did that
with mysterio
and tom holland i thought they might
have just let that play out on screen
well yeah because it would be a
significantly
different dynamic it would be a
different film in a lot of ways if they
had had a more head butter or more
adversarial dynamic from the get-go and
i think the betrayal is
just so much worse with the relationship
they built on screen and there's
again so many great scenes that i like
when i think of that movie
obviously you remember like the turn
that mysterio takes and all the chaos
but
i really do love some of those scenes
where they're just bonding and you're
really helping like
like when i watched it again i still
hoped mysterio
might be an okay guy and i think you
know
again i'm kind of shocked that so much
of at least the relationship dynamics in
these spider-man movies especially have
come
from you know dynamics found in the
process and then adapted from that you
know
but according to ned's actor jacob
batalon ned's relationship with betty
was basically developed by him and
actress and gory rice
he says they were given a lot of space
for improv they may not have lasted
super long as a couple but there's no
doubt they were adorable
i would totally kiss you but i think i
just threw up in my mouth a little
i i might have a mint it seems like
jacob battle on
you see that like what we were just
talking about like
that makes sense to me a lot more for
that choice to be like the choice for
jake gyllenhaal tom holland
really worked to me it makes more sense
for these two
yeah because they're like yes they have
the whole
joke bit of yeah they're on they sit
next to each other to play another
boyfriend and girlfriend to get off
on the plane the way back now they're
broken up like they have this joke about
it
but when they are boyfriend and
girlfriend they do have a chemistry that
is felt
and so this actually does make a lot of
sense to me to have them bond to this
degree
on and off camera um to really make that
feel a little bit more believable
yeah not just like you know uh detached
jokes just something that that's
only for humor but actually has a heart
to it so yeah it reminds you that they
have been like going to school together
yeah yeah yeah yeah that history you
don't really have to think about but
that really helps the scene yeah
a lot to do with all his characters
relationships with the chemistry between
peter and ned
we've never doubted the way they were
childhood best friends and the chemistry
between the actors off screen
is why it's so authentic apparently
because tom and jacob weren't given the
script days in advance
they never knew their lines which means
their interactions are purely the two
actors playing off one another
do you know him too yeah we met the
difference between success
if we needed any more proof that tom
holland is holding his own when it comes
to the rest of the marvel cast
this video is it watching wow not only
play superheroes but
be super cool when it comes to bringing
to life character
is nothing short of impressive let us
know if you have any other unscripted
spider-man moments we should discuss
thanks for watching the things fans
that's great you know
what's funny is i i think i didn't i
just say that
it would make more sense if they would
do that with tom holland and jacob
paddle
and then it ends on that note you know
jacob battle on he strikes me as the
kind of guy who
who's forget which one it was but i've
never actually seen a high school
musical movie
but you're missing out i remember on the
on a behind-the-scenes thing i saw like
some five-minute thing
they talked about how there was one
actor on set who took it's
way too like way more serious than
everyone else that he's one of the main
characters and he's very uh like in
character and stuff takes a little
serious
and i feel like with jacob babylon i can
imagine him being the kind of guy you're
like oh
ned you're the funny the guy in the
chair you're peter's best friend but i
can also imagine
that he probably takes it very serious
you know
he's probably one of those really really
like methodical actors in a lot of ways
he's very dedicated
yeah i i bet he is he's got ned leads
broken down to the finest
i wouldn't be surprised honestly well i
thought this was a great list this was a
lot of fun
glad we could do this yeah absolutely
and personally i like doing it in this
format yeah
for this video we're gonna do this for
trailers all right everybody
yeah mid explosion how crazy is that
explosion
it's pretty crazy but for these i like
checking out the list videos yeah at the
same time
though i'm like yeah there was something
about it i just felt a little off so i
actually prefer doing it in this type of
format
anyway guys leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that notification
bell
catch you guys soon oh hit that like
button
[Music]